[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show powered by icon plus capital
the vc firm sponsored by block fi and
luno so block five if you don't know
they do some really really cool interest
rates so i've left a link somewhere and
everywhere it's in the description it's
in the title whatever so yeah check them
out
joining me today um is a very good
friend of mine somebody who um has
actually helped me a lot in the space so
when i first got into the space um he
was very very kind and helped show me
the ropes and all that stuff um he's had
some amazing success in um
this current bull market if we're still
in a bull market i think we are um so i
can't wait to delve in and learn more
about it it is of course the lycon guy
john kim what's up john
what's up how are you
i am perfect because i'm on the layout
mama i made it i'm only leia show
so before we went live i told john that
um this was not going to be
inappropriate everything is going to be
professional and it's going to be it's
going to be very good it's going to be
very educational because i have a lot of
questions okay okay
and like i said you were one of the
people that were so kind to me um when i
first started growing on twitter and you
know you helped me a lot you helped me
with my podcast um so many different
things but you have a pretty interesting
story yourself um
and i don't know a lot about it and i
don't think a lot of people do so i want
to go into it because you're not
actually
you weren't actually born in america is
that correct you were born in south
korea
that's correct
so tell me about this
when did you so tell me about this
because obviously you're very like
american through and through but
i feel like you've kind of
gone through the american dream but i
want to go back a little bit
you moved your family moved when you
were younger from south korea what
happened
yeah so my my dad uh
decided that the only way that
we can succeed is for him to take us to
the united states because we were so
poor like
like really poor where you put
like these charcoals underneath the
floor to heat
heat the floor and we had this small hut
and all of us slept together in a row
and you have to walk
in the dark to go to the restroom in the
restroom there's just a hole in this
whole bunch of maggots and stuff so
every night
if i had to go to a restroom i'd just
cry walking over there because i didn't
want to be around
so
he left one year earlier he came to
arkansas at a chicken ranch
uh with work visa
and then a year later um he invited us
over got his green card and then we came
and then we lived in
texas
in a government
government housing apartment
and that's when i learned english real
quick because everybody kept messing
with me
um
back then you know asian people got made
fun of a lot because we're so different
you know
so uh i i learned uh cuss words real
quick because i had to fight a lot to to
protect myself so
yeah
that's insane i actually didn't know
that you were that poor
in south korea
very poor they're like if i think about
it i remember when i was younger my
dream
my as a kid my dream was to sleep on a
bed one time before i before i uh die
that that's how simple yeah that's how
simple my dream was and i remember one
of my birthdays when i was like six uh
five or six my dad brought one banana
because my dream was to eat a banana
and then he brought two gave me one by
myself for my birthday and gave one for
my sisters to share i remember i ate
mine i took it and they were beating me
and i ate the second one because
um
i really really wanted a banana i really
wanted to use my favorite food in the
world so when i came to america my dad
had a basket full of bananas at our
apartment
i haven't really liked banana ever since
too many memories too many memories no
because i ate so much of it because i
thought and then i got sick of it so now
i'm like when i look at a banana i'm not
i don't really
so how old were you when you came
seven seven
and do you remember it vividly was it
strange did you leave loads of friends
behind or were you just happy to come
leia when i got my dad had this old
lincoln continental like this long car
like a used long car when i when i when
i got out of the airplane and i saw him
saw the car
saw the apartment saw the bed
i literally thought i was in heaven
like i
i said we made it we made it and then
later i found that we were living in a
government apartment so
it wasn't that great but compared to
what i when i came from it was
unbelievably uh luxurious yeah
so do you ever think what your life
would have been like if you if your dad
didn't make the decision just to take
you all and go yeah i would have died
because uh when i came here in uh
fifth grade i i i had leukemia
so
i had medicaid and and the us us you
know texas paid for a lot of the stuff
where i got into remission
but if i was in korea i would i would
have died because um there is no aid if
you don't have money you're not you're
not getting treated you know so so you
were sick when you made the move or bef
or once you'd arrived uh about three
four years after i arrived
yeah
your story is so insane why do you never
i don't hear you speak about it much
i do i do sometimes when somebody gets
it out of me but it's nothing that i
want to voluntarily tell people it's
kind of
you know it's nothing too cool but yeah
it's fascinating because no no listen
it's fascinating because um you made
some really interesting remarks during
the whole um presidential campaign and
you know about um
it's a very divided time right and you
made a lot of interesting remarks so
america gave you a lot
so you must um
have an interesting perspective on
people who americans who hate america
because you've got a lot of those
you know and they say
i get it i i get where they're coming
from it's very emotional and you know uh
the media everything is hyping it up and
sensationalism and everything but i come
from a country to where
um like i always say this united states
is my stepfather south korea is my
father
but my stepfather raised me and gave me
opportunities that my father would never
have given me so if korea south korea
and the united states went to war i
would fight for the united states that's
how much i appreciate because
um i would have been dead i wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for the american way
american dream and american system
so that's why i was kind of very
passionate about people who are talking
about this country as
you know like inherently racist or
whatever i'm like listen there's racism
in every country but this is the only
country you can come with nothing
and literally become everything you know
so i'm very patriotic in that way but
i just decided you know
i got suspended on twitter
for for having an opinion
wait wait what happened go back i
actually never asked you about that why
were you suspended on twitter
because i talked about vaxx how it
should be
uh a freedom right to take it or not
take it and then i got a little
political and they didn't like it
so but
you know it's all good it's all good
maybe i just needed a fresh start so my
second account is that what 13 000 but
um it's yeah guys follow follow john kim
let's get him back up to 30k get him
even further than 30k 100 we have to do
that um
so so i want to know so you you moved
obviously to the states and you're
living in government housing where where
did it go from there because now you
have a lambo
so so you see the jump it's quite it's
quite a jump so i want to just
understand how did you get into crypto
because you you were involved obviously
quite early
what were the stages in your early
career like what were you doing before
crypto
um
so
so you know i
we came here we're all my dad worked all
the time worked two jobs uh as a janitor
uh my mom worked as a janitor and then
my dad did siding on the side so he was
just always gone so um when i was like
uh
17 i hurt my leg i made varsity football
and uh i hurt my leg and i couldn't play
anymore so i quit school and i started
to go into life of fighting and crying
so
um but in 2009 uh 2008 everything
changed my son was born 2007.
i just felt like i i really needed to
change my life i felt this
responsibility i felt a love that i've
never felt before
um i remember when my son was born and i
looked at him and i said
dude i don't even know you you haven't
done anything for me but why do i feel
like i can lay down my life for you what
love what kind of feeling is this what
kind of love is this that i'm feeling
and that literally changed the way i saw
the world and then um 2000
i started homeless ministry
i wanted to give back to society so i
lived in a homeless shelter for two
months just to see how it feels not that
i needed to
uh and and i remember
the cool story is when i when i walked
into the homeless shelter to stay there
because i i wanted to lead by example i
wanted to tell people that i know how it
feels right
there was bed bugs and like pea stains
all over the small mattress and uh i
remember like for a week just kept
biting now itching whatever after a week
the bucks
me and me and the bucks became cool they
stopped biting me and it was comfortable
you know so um i did that for three
years i started i pitched the tent in
downtown dallas and i fed one homeless
person
and it grew to feeding a thousand
homeless person a week
um
it was my full-time job i didn't get
paid i didn't get donations that's why
i'm so adamant about not not getting
paid or or getting donations on crypto
because i've done it for three years and
i i left i didn't make any money but i
left the legacy that there you can
help people without taking stuff from
them you know so
um i did that for three years and then
um i took one of the homeless person
inside my home gave him a job and
everything and he ended up robbing me
and i realized that badly or
just robbed the whole house you know and
left
but but
what can they do right like that's all
they know
so
i and we became cool afterwards i
forgave him it's all good
and then after that i realized you know
like
so 99 of the homeless people are setting
their ways because they're older they're
like 30 35 40 50. and i said you know
what
i think i've done my part i need to
graduate this this homeless ministry and
then later on i really wanted to help
young children because i feel like young
children you can actually change the
trajectory of their lives
so
um and then i went to business so in
2012 i got into business and in five
years i opened 15 businesses sleeping
four hours a day
because i had no high school diploma i
had i had no money i borrowed ten
thousand dollars from my dad and then i
opened 15 businesses so what were the
businesses it was cell phone stores and
pre-paid cell phone stores it was led
lighting general contracting interior
design
you told me this i remember
so i mean you know that's why
i'm so i really want um underdogs to win
you know because i i
everybody told me you don't have a
husband you don't have this you don't
have that but then i spoke at johns
hopkins i spoke at u-pen and i just want
people to know like no nobody in this
world is going to give me a restriction
right nobody's going to tell me i
overcame death i overcame chemotherapy
as a child right losing all my hair
getting picked on
i overcame that i overcame
gang life i overcame counting in jail
multiple times you know so
um
i just i just want when i die
i want people to know
see me as a person that that inspires
them to be able to do whatever the heck
they want if they can imagine it and if
this is the most important part
um
if you're an underdog and you don't have
that much to offer you must work two
times harder
right that's why i only slept four four
hours a day for like five years
to achieve what i achieved so
um don't think that your success is
gonna come just by declaring it
just just know you're gonna have to be
willing to suffer more than anyone else
around you
then
your story will become great
so what would you say
the most important thing out of all of
that you've learned other than you know
working hard and not expecting
everything just to come to you but would
you say the most important thing is that
you learnt
being that you still wait that you still
apply today sorry yeah so being brutally
honest with yourself
when i wake up in the morning i look at
myself and i you know it
i'm brutally honest with myself and when
you do that your ego gets crushed your
pride gets crushed
and then you you realize that you still
need to make improvements and you still
need to try to become a better person
um
so i think so many people are blinded by
their um
by who they are and they look out
and judge everyone else
for me as soon as i start judging
somebody i look within
because maybe i'm projecting something
that i'm not seeing so when you do that
people around you will love you people
around you won't like wants to be around
you because you're not some egotistical
like prideful maniac that is always
trying to say the last word and always
trying to you know take the spotlight so
um
yeah i think brutally being honest with
yourself and
crazy work ethic which starts in the gym
like i fight i fight weights in the gym
every day and i win
so when it comes to life
it's not that hard like if i can kill it
in the gym i come out i can kill it in
life too so self-discipline being
brutally honest and work ethic like no
one else and work ethic does not come
overnight guys it comes
years and years of really like pushing
and pushing and pushing until it becomes
and one of my coaches told me this and
it was such a great line
it says amateurs do it until they become
good
professionals do it
until it becomes automatic
you know what i mean so i feel like my
life right now is all an automatic mode
because i've been doing it for so long
so yeah
that's amazing i think everything that
you've done is so commendable um and i
wish you talk about it more because it's
such a fascinating we never see that
side of you we always see like the jokes
and the laughs but you know i want to
see i want to see the other side um
so how then did you
hear about crypto your son was born
that was 2008 i think he said
same time
yeah sorry
so how did you hear about crypto 2017
like it was early like january or
something um i was keep hearing about
bitcoin
then i came home and my ex my wife at
the time
she said i said hey have you heard of
bitcoin he said have you heard aetherium
and we're like you know why don't we
just kind of dabble into this and then
uh i remember wait but how did you hear
about it though like why did you just on
the internet just like i don't know it
wasn't from anyone's particular i just
kept hearing about it you know
so i remember i went to a t-mobile
prepaid t-mobile store
and i bought my first bitcoin at 800
through liberty x or something like i
gave them cash i had to sit there and
wait until they sent it to my wallet and
i was like this is so scary
i'm literally giving them like cash and
i'm getting this digital money that i
completely do not understand
so uh and my wife i think at the time
bought ethereum at like ten dollars or
five dollars
but
we trust me we sold it all you sold it
all
i mean because back then there was no
thing i didn't know what haul meant
all i know is like oh this thing went up
a little bit less sell you know so later
i learned that having diamond hands is
is something that you acquire over a
long period of time so yeah
but you're known as the litecoin guy
right
do you still work with charlie lee 100
i'm litecoin first always will be amp is
my second baby that's gonna take
litecoin to the masses uh but here's how
i came across like one yeah um i was
trading at the time right i was trading
stocks at the time and then i got into
crypto and i started trading i started
day trading thinking i was a genius
because i i mean i was killing it
um but as i was trying to move bitcoin
through exchanges
and you guys don't know this like this
is before binance like when binance
first came like i was going back and
forth and i sent bitcoin and i'm sitting
there like oh my god
i'm losing so much trade because this
dang thing will not confirm you know
wait what were you trading on
what how are you sending coinbase like
btc
finance like i was just going through
all these exchanges and every time i
send bitcoin i would just lose lose so
much on the trade
but then i found litecoin it's like boom
i was like oh man i love litecoin
because this is the perfect coin to move
between exchanges and then i started
doing my research and then i really
realized that uh litecoin
is that coin that
not only could it be a store value but a
good means of exchange
and um
you know
satoshi nakamoto is not here right so
there's a lot of battles to be fought
between
the the huddlers the miners and and the
developers and i just felt like charlie
lee being alive um could give
litecoin a better direction faster
until it became uh robust and and where
the litecoin didn't need him anymore so
um yeah that's that's how i fell in love
with liquid
and you put a lot of money into litecoin
didn't you like you went all in in
yeah 2018 yeah august 6 2018 i sold
everything
uh i saw my house and then gave the
proceeds
the house proceeds to my ex at the time
and i said you gotta let me do this i
cannot do anything else right now
because i'm
so passionate about you know spreading
the gospel of litecoin and and getting
people into the space before it's too
late and then i sold everything and then
i left in my litecoin truck
and then i started to
live a life of digital nomad
so wait to to put all that so to put
everything that you own after the main
ball run like after big one hits 20k
to put it all into litecoin you got to
have some serious conviction so i'd love
to understand where that conviction came
from
so the conviction came from this okay
um
this is one of the uh
revelation or or
or understanding that i feel like i got
from from the upper skies or something
i started
for some weird reason i fell in love
with a calculator because i suck at like
i'm the only asian dude in the world
okay that sucks at math okay everyone
who copied me in high school failed
right i'm not i am no charlie um
i started playing with calculator and i
started to crunch numbers about how i
could put a million dollars in my hands
with my business
and i realized i just don't have enough
time
to literally like
even if i took a job every day the like
led lighting business whatever i just
like the numbers don't add up i cannot
retire
you know and i was like okay there's got
to be a better way and i realized this
we are living a addition
plus life
and i needed to be on a multiplication
life in order for me to retire and
succeed
and i looked
and i and i looked at all my businesses
and i looked at everything that i was
doing i said john
the race has started way before you even
if you
and and i like experientially right i
only slept four hours and even when i
ran that hard i could not even catch up
because the game was so far beyond me
right i could be a good middle class and
make a little money and have a house and
live with this life
but to make it to be able to retire i
was like i need to live the
multiplication life and the game has
started way before me and i looked at
bitcoin litecoin and cryptocurrency i
was like
you know what the starting line is not
that far
like there's some ogs that left in 2011
2010 whatever but i'm like
i
2017 i could still see the starting line
this is the only chance i have in my
life
to be able to change the trajectory of
my financial life
and with my work ethic be able to catch
up to them because if i'm willing to
sleep four hours then i better see some
some kind of uh
progress right yeah so um i went from
life of addition to life of
multiplication and i knew this was my
chance it would never come again in my
lifetime so i went all in
on that multiplication life which was
cryptocurrency yeah
that is literally how i feel right now
um i i've never heard it put in that's
in that way i think that's great um you
know looking at it as an addition like
versus a multiplication like you think
that's a great way to look at it um
because it's true you're not gonna
you're not gonna retire
nicely on your nine to five um some
people say they've done it
don't believe it till i see it um i've
seen the opposite i've seen the absolute
opposite i've seen people give their
life to the man and then
you know the game
the game is designed for you to stay an
employee stay in middle class the game
is designed to be that and
cryptocurrency takes that game turns it
upside down and gives
a a normal person a chance to reach for
the stars and actually reach it
so you went all in 2018 um so fast
forward wait wait not yet wait i don't
fast forward to the to the bull market
yeah i want to what was it like in that
period because there was a period of
time where things were just down it was
down for like three and a half years um
and that's hard i remember you you were
sleeping in different places you didn't
have like you said you're doing the
digital nomad lifestyle but it was
difficult so tell me about that journey
through those few years
i mean it was it was difficult but it
wasn't impossible right like i
i like difficult i mean i
being in a gym
everything that hurts that is difficult
that you don't want to do is probably
the one thing that you need to do to
like gain muscle and to go over overcome
so i already have that mentality to
where but when litecoin hit 22 i was
like
damn i'm broke i am
i was not interested did you invest in
wait what price did you invest in
my first one was like i think 10 bucks
right 10 8 or 10 bucks and then i i
bought all the way to 350.
like so i'm telling people like we've
all been there we've all bought high you
know
but um i stopped trading when i when i
got on the road and i remember just
sleeping in roche motels and
and like my truck and i had a
i had a membership a lifetime so i would
go into a 24-hour lifetime and sleep on
the sofa and stuff like that and my
friends the lycom community would let me
sleep in their couches
but um i remember when it when my
portfolio just dropped 90 something
percent
and i said to myself um
this is not hard enough
because i still
yeah because i knew that i still had an
option to go back
to where my ex-wife was
and to stay there and have a place to
stay and i was like no this is not bad
enough it needs to be worse because the
story that i'm creating
cannot this can't be
this is not bad enough
and so
when it really hit the worst was um like
march
when colgate happened
you know
that's when uh i i hit rock bottom in my
relationship everything just like
and i was stuck in dallas in a small
room
um with my mom yeah and with a broken
rib and covet and and i said okay okay
god
this is it the this is the bottom we're
going up from here i remember saying
that to myself because i've never been
in a situation where i've really felt
like there's no option
you know and that's what everything i
had i think i had the best year in 2020
so all went up from there that's
unbelievable i remember that because
that's when you and i had met yeah um
sorry i remember that really well so
yeah so you know litecoin like
everything else started to go up how was
it
um
you know charlie
like i
i'm so grateful
for charlie lee because not only was he
a good friend to me but he was he was
uh
my mentor uh he was my friend um he
helped me
one of the story like um people don't
know is
when i was broke and my mom didn't have
a place to stay
um charlie
he sent me some money to take care of
her mom you know so um oh wow yeah so
that's amazing yeah so for me um
crypto
i'm sorry i didn't mean to i just i was
so curious
i didn't mean to no it's cool so
it's not it's not it's not about money
and if you ask the close people around
me i never did it for money is money
important yeah but i i went out because
i wanted to prove the world wrong you
know that's my number one thing and then
along the way you know people like
charlotte like really helped me so
um i'm i'm very loyal to the people that
that like help me without asking for
anything in return so um yeah that's why
i'm still
uh litecoin number one all the way until
it hits four digits i i'm not gonna stop
um promoting it and and talking about it
yeah it's really no not your bad no it's
really interesting and i appreciate
sharing it because um you know it really
is all about the community i'm sorry
it is all about the community um you
know you really do find like-minded
people who really have a bigger vision
and have a greater vision for the world
and want to make um you know make the
world a better place and help everyone
who you know who's part of that so i had
no idea that about charlie lee so that's
really cool that you said he helps he
helps a lot of people behind the scenes
and does not ever take credit or does
not ever talk about it so that's why i'm
just saying you know there's a lot of
dark people in this space that tries to
scam people um charlie is one of the
most
ethical morally upright person i've ever
met in my life and that's why i'm i'm so
bullish on litecoin because it's doing
everything right the right way you know
so yeah yeah i feel like i need to buy a
bag of litecoin now i have a little bit
i feel like i need to buy more i feel i
feel like i do
so so what happened so so right so
the market started to go up things
started to do better
and
you obviously suddenly were in a much
better position things became a lot more
positive so at what point in 2020 did
you look at your portfolio and you were
like this is it like the hard the
hardship is over i've made it
um i think uh
towards like september
okay september 2020. i knew i knew i
made it
and and and like i told people but
people don't know this
uh i made my friend 12 like i think
upwards of 10 million dollars and then
um i didn't want anything you know um
but
my friend bought me the lamborghini
as a gift for uh you know
so i thought that was a cool story um
it is i don't i would never be able to
buy a lamborghini i i just don't have it
in me to to purchase something that
expensive
but to get it as a gift um it was it was
it was tremendous for me and then to be
able to convince the dealer to accept
litecoin so as so it was 884 litecoin
for that lamborghini and um
and another cool thing is my friend told
me this he said uh i want you to enjoy
the hell out of it you can't sell it you
gotta ride it until the wheels fall off
or upgrade it
take care of your children give them a
good time so my my son
came to field trip to
the mall next to my house in plano and
it was two two school bus full of kids
came here for a field trip i remember
that day i pulled up in my lamborghini
with the top down and it was a
tremendous experience for my son
and i took him out to the back in a
parking lot and let him drive the
lamborghini as a 14 year old so
yeah so it was a great experience all
around how you can use a car like a
supercar
to raise your sons
like you know make him look good and
allow him to enjoy it so
yeah it's
i think my story is that not not i
didn't make great investments or i was a
great trader
but
i've helped enough people
to where they
they gave me back
some of the things and do you remember
how um
i helped a ufc fighter recover a wallet
and i told him no you you're my icon his
name is chelsea and i say dude you're my
hero i used to watch you on pay-per-view
and then after we recovered it uh
you know he sent me half of what was in
there
so so the story
so what i'm trying to say is like i
never asked for money
but for some reason the universe found a
way to reward me somehow and i and i
can't i'm not trying to spiritualize
that no you can spiritualize it okay
yeah
so i just felt like my my whole journey
wasn't about me buying and selling and
hobbling it was about me doing
everything that i believe was the right
thing to do and i was my conviction
stood firm even if i didn't have money
even if i went broke i did not cross
that line and ask people for money
whatever which i could have
and when i did that
the universe
and the people around me rewarded me up
with was a lot of money now
you know because at that time it wasn't
that much money but now if you think
about it yeah
you know
so
it pays to be a good person i think
that's amazing you know people are
always so cynical about life and people
are always so negative um and so jaded
as well i remember you were quite jaded
at one point you were just like
no leia if you haven't seen the world
the way i've seen the world and i'm just
there all like bright and positive and
you're just like you haven't seen what
i've seen
um but it's nicer but it's nice to see
you know like the the other side of that
so
you're staying in a really cool place
right now tell me about it
oh yeah this is a
high-rise resort style
24-hour concierge
free valet parking
awesome cool awesome conference rooms
i don't know it's just last year i i
remember
i did a live stream and i said uh um
next year
i'm gonna live in a high rise and i'm
gonna have a lambo and i declared it and
for some reason
i wanted
to keep my word
and so i i live in this awesome place
and i have a lamborghini
um it's just um
i just you know leia
i just maybe it's the chip on my
shoulder maybe it's just the way i grew
up you know
but
like
i don't pursue money but i i what i what
i would die for is to prove to the world
that that that i'm right
that if i do it in a certain way that i
can succeed because 99 of the people in
this world are following money are doing
like all these stuff to make money right
and i just felt i just wanted to show
the world that if you have a conviction
if you
if you're set in your ways and you and
you and you do what's right and you add
value to people without asking anything
back
that you can succeed and i truly believe
leia like even when we first met i was
like
leah this is what i do if you want to
start a podcast here everything this is
this is what i 100 this is what it is
and and you were like john thank you i'm
like leia
i don't want anything from me i just
want you to freaking kill this game
and
and i called it i said you are the next
big thing
i did didn't i
and i said i'm not a big the only yeah
going i was gonna make a stupid joke
yeah go on when we first met how many
followers you have like eleven thousand
fifteen thousand or something you're
like a hundred thirty three thousand
so oh yeah today yeah no so i feel i
feel good
and and and you know the people who
receiving it know too
when you help somebody without expecting
anything in return the person receiving
it can receive with a smile and they're
they're very glad right but once you
have that look where oh you better pay
me back or something that's when things
get kind of kind of weird so yeah i
think that's that's what i'm the most
proud of that i did not waver i did not
uh take the shortcut and and and i made
it this way yeah
i feel like um
because so i'm kind of like you in some
sense in that you know you like to do
the right thing you like to the right
wing you like to be a good person but i
often feel
that we saw we so you said like you have
this chip on your shoulder because you
have to prove that the world is a
certain way but you don't think maybe
you have to prove it is that way because
like it would be too um
it would be too hard to
believe that there is a world where you
can succeed by
being bad and selfish and evil
it would be too hard to accept that
there there's a world like that which i
think there is it's true it's it's i
mean
mostly it's like that you know so i mean
even when i was doing the homeless
mission everybody told me to ask for
donations from church and ask for
personal donations i was like no
no
i will feed thousand people without
donations it will happen
and then i went to donut stores on
sunday and got the leftover donuts went
to walmart asked for the leftover
chickens like it it worked out it worked
out you know so
so now everything's worked out you've
got your nice lambo you've got your
high-rise your valet parking and all
that all the fun stuff what what's going
on now like what
what is day-to-day
um
i i i don't have anything to do like my
only responsibility in life right now is
um responsibility is my live stream
my podcast
jason and ben on tuesdays that's the
only thing that i'm
um see this is what i think retirement
is retirement is you don't have to be
anywhere anytime because of someone
you know you can do whatever you want
anytime anywhere so right now i just
work out a lot and i'm building up my
body and my health and just kind of
relaxing um because i ran so hard for
four years
i wanted one year
just to be able to do what i want and
then maybe if i catch another bug next
year but
i'm not going back on my word guys
we are going to 10x
this year from january so
that's that's so so so wait so okay so
just yeah let's just get your thoughts
on the bull market so what is going on
we obviously had that major major dump
yesterday ten thousand dollars
unbelievable on the day that el salvador
recognized baker's legal tender pulls
back by ten thousand dollars something
funny there
yeah um
so so what are your predictions for the
rest of this year do you think this is
just uh
a healthy pullback taking us on to new
highs in a few weeks few months well you
know
last year i think it was october when uh
me jessica
and ben we're live and i told ben
um bitcoin's gonna hit 35k before the
end of year and he said how's that gonna
happen in like a matter of weeks i'm
like just watch
i was i was i was late by five days
right
then and i told people that lycone was
gonna hit uh all-time high 360 uh in
april um i was off uh it hit uh five
days later it was in may
um so what i'm saying is
bitcoin i'm always right
what i'm saying is i'm always right no
no i'm not saying that's to say i'm
always right i'm not emotional if i said
something
i'm going to stick with it whether the
market's up down fun is whatever so i
call 250k bitcoin this year blow off top
litecoin will be
above four digits and you know amp will
be above 75 cents and i'm i'm sticking
to that and
i'm i'm rarely wrong when i when i feel
this
gut conviction in my in my in my gut so
um so this is just the beginning even
for you i just want to tell you
we have just started
right we have just started in this
crypto game and if you have over a
hundred thousand dollars in this game
right now
you're you're going to be a
multi-millionaire in the next two three
years and i mean you'll be a millionaire
this year but you'll be a
multi-multi-millionaire in the next four
years and and because a wise man once
told me uh bitcoin litecoin 10 x's every
four years because it's written in the
code
it's true it's written in the code
that's brilliant no it's so it's so
interesting i i hope you're right um you
know i wanna um i i do agree with you i
think right now is just the land of
opportunity so much opportunity just to
build some serious serious wealth uh
don't hope hopeless for the week believe
i called
i called you okay i said
you're the next big thing okay you 10x
in your follower account so why can't
bitcoin 10x come on come on
it's true okay so all right fine so just
finally then like what advice would what
advice would you give me i'm coming to
the states you know i'm coming what
advice would you give me
number one be careful because you ain't
ugly okay
you gotta be careful i'm ugly if you get
on the wrong side of me so just listen
if you're ugly you can go down the dark
alleyway all day long nobody gonna mess
with you okay so number one be careful
and have fun
and and
you know
you know lately zooby came to united
states and he did so much he he affected
so many lives
and i just hope that you coming to
america uh you will change a lot of
people's perspectives and minds and like
bless and inspire
many people and at one point
i'm gonna come see you wherever you are
miami austin dallas
el salvador
i may come see you and be your bodyguard
we'll do it we'll do it john i want to
thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure and i appreciate you being so
open and honest because i had so many
questions i wanted to know more about
the guy behind all the jokes and the
litecoin
thank you leia i appreciate it hey
everyone
thanks for tuning in guys don't forget
to follow john on twitter and don't
forget to tune in next week for another
episode alright we'll see you then
[Applause]
[Music]